[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
eric woerth bonjour bonjour député de
l'oise président de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
bonjour et on commence par ce budget
eric woerth ce budget présenté lundi
avec des chiffres qui donnent le vertige
107% 16% de dead 6,7 pour cent de
déficit un budget hors normes
est-ce que vous voterez ce budget tel
qu'il a été présenté est ce que c'est un
budget qui vous convient une question un
peu un peu rapide avant même l'examen du
plan farr entrer dans le détail
non enfin je priori nous ne voterons pas
le budget on est une opposition
responsable
on a fait beaucoup de propositions que
ce soit sur le plan de relance lui même
dès le mois de mai on est saisi le
gouvernement d'un certain nombre d'idées
certaines ont été reprises ou pas il ya
des sujets aussi qu'ils ne peuvent pas
nous convenir et puis je trouve que
surtout le manque de visibilité dans un
moment où on a besoin un peu d'éclaircir
l'avenir même s'il est compliqué tu
chacun le sait est né n'est pas là on a
un budget très très statique c'est le
principe d'un projet de loi de finances
mais peut-être qu'on aurait pu autour du
projet de loi de finances
branché ou greffer quelques scénarios au
moins deux scénarios un scénario dans
laquelle la crise se poursuit
ce budget est construit pendant la
période de crise donc la crise se
poursuit ou un scénario elle s'estompe
au fur et à mesure du temps ce qui nous
aurait permis quand même de voir comment
les choses sont financés vais faire deux
buts et non je parle de ce scénario je
dis il faut il faut un texte qui est
votée bien sûr mais ce texte voté aurait
pu être accompagnés de deux scénarios
sérieuse solide macro économiques
montrant le niveau il a anticipé d'ores
et déjà le retour d'un pic épidémique
donc tous avaient été envisagées des
jades dès cet été je peux pas vous dire
le pic épidémique il est envisagé déjà
depuis depuis le printemps depuis le
mois de mai quand on a commencé à à ceux
des confits né il a été indiqué
attention aux rebonds
le le budget il répond à une situation
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui la
constate il est curieusement d'ailleurs
plus optimiste que le consensus des
économistes et des institutions comme la
banque de france ou le cd eux alors que
sur 2020 il était plus plus plus plus
bénéficient les îles et la prévision je
pense que l'absence de + 8 % vous n'y
croyez pas je je ne sais pas mais en
vérité personne ne sait personne ne seul
il ya un rebond y aura une forte
croissance après une énorme dépression
il y aura évidemment une forte
croissance
il ya toujours une forte croissance
après une dépression mais je vois
simplement que les chiffres sont tout à
fait considérable en termes
d'endettement
on a l'impression que tout le monde s'en
moque aujourd'hui delà de la dette et à
un nombre de gens incroyables qui
explique qu'il faut pas la rembourser
qui explique que c'est pas très grave
que la marche n'est pas le cas du
rez-de-jardin cas clairement dit bruno
le maire qui sciemment dit ce serait
irresponsable de dire qu'on ne la
rembourse pas ouais enfin si après
savoir si vous croyez que le
gouvernement est capable de faire cet
endettement sans augmenter les impôts
par exemple hier mais enfin c'est pas le
cas et c'est le gouvernement et dit ce
qu'il veut mais je présente aussi des
textes et quand il présente des textes
il ne donne aucune visibilité sur le
financement
aujourd'hui ce budget est bourré de
déficit pendant bien longtemps
il n'y a aucun financement qui soit
clairement électeurs mais parle de
structurel par exemple la réforme des
retraites une plaisanterie mais si une
plaisanterie enfin je suis des parlottes
tout ça fasse une plaisanterie je pense
que je pense que le gouvernement il va
se contenter une file et on l'a beaucoup
interrogé là-dessus ne répond pas il
répond qu sur des généralités
on n'a pas besoin de généralités on a
besoin de choses précises le
gouvernement il termine son mandat dans
dix huit mois c'est pas et pendant cinq
ans dans 18 mois
donc est-ce que le plan de relance il
est au fond le l'alpha et l'oméga de
l'action gouvernementale sur les 18 mois
qui viennent pourraient le dire on
pourrait dire moi ce que je souhaite
c'est je vais d'un gouvernement qui
relancent point final et puis et puis je
ne fais rien d'autre
rien de structurantes on va alors est-ce
que sur le gouvernement souhaite à peu
près poursuivre ou presque entamé un
pardon parce que pas grand chose a été
fait on aimait un programme de réformes
soir par luc également justement les
scandales des retraites ce qu'il est
important de dire aux gens finalement
d'être transparent et c'est ce que vous
sont
et vouloir dire dire aux gens clairement
qu' on ne pourra pas s'embêter de cette
manière s'en faire des réformes
structurantes type la réforme des
retraites évidemment sans augmenter les
impôts sans faire des coupes claires
aussi dans les effectifs de la fonction
publique tel que peut être pas par les
germes invite tous à moi j'attends des
propositions du gouvernement je pense
que le gouvernement il gouverne donc
normalement le gouvernement il propose
quoi il met sur la table un certain
nombre de propositions
il faudrait faire origines nous n'avons
aucune aucune précision sur les sur les
choses
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait fleuve le
gouvernement il annonce ainsi un budget
dans lesquelles le niveau d'endettement
et le niveau de déficit va être
extrêmement forts sur les prochaines
années
il a abordé cette crise nous avons
abordé cette crise dans une situation de
faiblesse relative très importante dans
une situation bien plus faible que la
plupart des autres pays le chômage de
masse il était déjà malheureusement même
si les choses s'améliorent il est signé
du chômage de 2 à st juste avant la
crise non va coûter si je suis tout seul
à courir les jeux olympiques je gagne
mais il y en a d'autres à côté c'est
plus compliqué donc en termes relatifs
en termes relatifs les autres pays
c'était beaucoup plus restructurer
beaucoup plus réformé à la fois en
termes de déficit et le déficit public
français avant la crise étaient 80 % du
déficit de la zone euro dont un tout
petit souci donc des priorités n'avait
pas été prise et les réformes maire
n'avait pas été fait pendant la période
de beau temps c'est à dire pendant la
période de croissance
et ça c'est selon vous il faut expliquer
aux gens jusqu'où on va jusqu'où on va
en termes de déficit on est resté sur le
quoi qu'il en coûte ça n'a pas été
remplacé cette formule il faut
aujourd'hui savoir jusqu'où va-t-on dans
ce budget il ya plusieurs types de
dépenses et des dépenses d'urgence cela
il faut les faire il faut les prendre
les hôtels et cafés les restaurants qui
sont fermées aux touristes c'est le
chômage partiel
évidemment il faut le faire nous avions
voté pour ces mesures est évidemment on
accompagne le gouvernement quand il
n'est si vous votre force et de les
rallonger oui
d'urgence bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
parce qu'on en a besoin et c'est
nécessaire et plutôt efficace maintenant
ça coûte une fortune mais plutôt
efficace et si on ne le fait pas alors
évidemment on rentre dans un an dans un
système beaucoup plus vertigineux il ya
une deuxième type de deux mesures qui
sont des mesures de transformation
économique c'est-à-dire une crise est
une opportunité
tout le monde dit ça et c'est vrai il
faut saisir la chance d'une crise entre
guillemets pour aller plus vite dans ce
que l'on doit faire
donc il ya des mesures où on va plus
vite dans le domaine de l'écologie dans
le domaine de la transformation
numérique etc terrienne notamment mon
domaine du sanitaire dans le domaine de
l'industrie elle sait très bien
il faut bien montrer à côté commença ses
finances et parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de le financer de la même manière
que l'urgence et puis à des troisièmes
troisième mesure qui sont pas du tout
négligeable c'est que la crise est un
alibi et donc on plombe les dépenses de
fonctionnement sert qu'à des dépenses de
fonctionnement on y résister depuis
longtemps je pensais d augmentation du
nombre de fonctionnaires à des
augmentations aussi financeurs pas des
primes d augmentation durable et ces
augmentations durable on va devoir les
financiers va durablement c'est à dire
pendant toujours c'est pas non plus le
même type de fille d'un sport et c'est
pas le même type de comportement on a
l'impression que chaque fois qu'un
ministre demande des milliards il les
obtient dans le domaine de la culture je
suis très léger d'or la culture il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas de sujet de cette
nature mais quand même quand vous vous
dites on va on va augmenter les crédits
de du patrimoine et dieu sait qu'on
s'est battu pour qu'il y ait des crédits
de patrimoine mais quand on se dit
maintenant on va augmenter les crédits
du patrimoine quand en même temps on a
un niveau de dépenses publiques
absolument considérable et une
incapacité à financer on se dit ça n'a
aucun lien avec la crise ça n'a aucun
lien avec la crise qu'on le fasse et
chaque dépense individuellement elle est
toujours légitime elle est toujours
légitime
maintenant quand on les additionne on se
dit on peut pas payer
mais alors si on vous écoute on a
l'impression que tout a été un peu
mélangé est ce que vous dites scellier
danger à lui il aurait fallu un texte
avec les mesures du plan d'urgence que
vous auriez voter puisque l'urgence
était là et un au texte avec un budget a
plus moyen terme avec des économies pour
rembourser la dette et le débat il
révèle besoin
on avait besoin si on avait été un tout
petit peu si on avait voulu un peu
innové je veux dire que la volatilité
est absolument extrêmes on ne peut rien
prévoir et que donc évidemment il faut
un budget a essayé de fixer un cap un
différend il fallait des scénarios il
fallait greffer des scénarios de 2,2
exploratoire des finances publiques de
notre pays pour 2021 et puis
probablement les prolonger un peu sur
2022 et 2023 il ya rien
les mesures du plan d'urgence de ce
budget ça c'était pas la bonne solution
et les mesures du plan d'urgence doivent
être dans le budget elles sont forcément
il ya une urgence il faut évidemment il
répondre et puis il fallait évidemment
qu'il ya un plan de financement et c'est
ce que je dis poursuivre sur 2022 2023
comment en réalité on absorbe cela la
volatilité elle est extrême je vous
prends un exemple un seul exemple en
deux ans en lors du du projet de loi de
financement de la numéro 3 cd rom à 2
juillet au match juillet le gouvernement
il prévoyait un déficit de l'état pour
la fin de 2020 de 225 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire grosso modo 100 % des
recettes fiscales donc à chiffre
absolument énorme
225 milliards dont 2 mois après en fin
fin du mois de septembre sur la même fin
2020 le gouvernement prévoit 195
milliards d'euros de déficit c'est aussi
un chiffre absolument énorme et moins
énorme que le premier ya 30 milliards
d'écart sur un seul chiffre sur le seul
déficit de l'état il ya 30 milliards
d'écart de prévisions entre le moi la
fin du mois de deux vols début du mois
de juillet le texte est voté la fin du
mois de juillet entre la fin du mois de
juillet et la fin du mois de mai la fin
du mois de mai qu'on ne sait pas qu'il
ya des recettes de plus qu'il ya des
dépenses supplémentaires que la crise
avance dans ce tell tale cadre que tel
ministre obtient une une une rallonge
parce que parce que cette rallonge au
fond lui avait promis ekiza n'a pas dit
avec la crise mais on le fait quand même
failli un peu de tout il ya une sorte de
on est en aidant des finances disant
paré et ne pouvons pas rester comme ça
vous nous décrivez c'est un gouvernement
qui a lâché les chevaux budgétaire en
fait qui est complètement le mors aux
dents
ouais je pense qu'une vraie volonté de
de dire il faut qu'on est con soit
raisonnable on n'a pas de souveraineté
de n'a pas d'avenir s'ouvre pour la
france si on ne domine pas un tout petit
peu notre processus budgétaire le budget
c'est pas de la comptabilité 1 c'est pas
un document avec plein de chiffres et
des tableaux auxquels personne ne
comprend rien le budget sera au fond les
finances du pays
comme les finances des ménages s'est
relativement important pour s'assurer
d'un avenir c'est pas parce que vous
avez un bon budget que vous avez un
avenir serein et c'est pas parce que
vous avez un petit peu d'argent que vous
êtes un couple heureux
enfin quand même ça facilite de temps en
temps un peu les choses c'est un budget
sans projet d'un budget dans lequel en
réalité on est à la fois sur l'urgence
un peu de transformation écologique un
peu de transformation numérique
et puis derrière on affiche des
objectifs mais qu'on est absolument pas
certain de pouvoir tenir compte tenu des
événements extérieurs c'est pour ça que
je trouve que ça aurait été très très
inédit et serait bien correspondu à la
bien sûr une bonne correspondance avec
la la période que de que de travailler
un tout petit peu autrement sur ce
budget on l'avait proposé ce n'est je
n'ai pas faire puisque vous parlez de
l'avenir est ce que vous dites que ce
budget de nature à donner confiance aux
particuliers confiance aux entreprises
pour relancer l'économie
non pas du tout fois je pense pas je
pense pas qu'on puisse avoir confiance
avec un tel niveau de d'endettement ou
un tel niveau d'absence de réponse sur
comment on finance
lorsque le gouvernement crée la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
c'est c'est l'objet de beaucoup du du
plfss l'aïe qui arrive d'ailleurs entre
nous c'est le budget de la sécu pardon
le budget de la sécurité sociale entre
nous quand vous regardez les chiffres du
budget initial de 2020 et que vous
regardez les chiffres de prévisions
aujourd'hui le déficit de la sécurité
sociale il est multiplié par 9 x 9
donc c'était absolument considérable et
est ce vraiment le moment pour créer
optiquement sur le sur le papier une
cinquième branche sur la dépendance a
mais la dépendance et
hyper important il faut qu'on essaye d
videmment enfin et c'est hyper important
d'avoir un projet de dépendance sérieux
et lorsque le gouvernement
le créer sur le papier il se pose pas la
question du financement ou alors il
armait sa pose bien sûr mais la remet à
plus tard
il n'y a pas de réponse à cela on ne
sait pas comment parler d'une conférence
de financement septembre c'est la
rentrée
vous avez déjà vu des conférences de
financement qui aboutissent à des
résultats
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé sur les
retraites on fait des conférences de
financement quand on sait pas comment
financer c'est comme ça que ça arrive
alors la création
ce budget de la sécu mais bien sûr que
non alors fallait la mettre complètement
faux le maître complètement avec des
réponses précises sur comment on finance
les 4 5 ou 6 milliards de plus par
rapport au crédit de la dépendance qui
aujourd'hui sur d'une trentaine de
milliards comment on fait pour assurer
un service de 2,2 au français concernant
ce moment assez terrible dans la dans la
vie ce dernier moment de la vie qui est
le moment où ou un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes deviennent dépendants c'est
un tout petit peu besoin d'être regardée
avec sérieux quoi alors cela dit sérieux
fait l'objet quand même d'un rapport de
laurent vacher qui a été missionné
justement surveillance est question de
diagnos mans il ya des queues ayez que
des impôts n'ont mis que des impôts dans
le rapport de monsieur v chèque est
sûrement quelqu'un de très bien c'est
lulu relie fait ce coup lorsqu'on lui
demande d'ailleurs très inventif mais
très inventif pour créer beaucoup
d'impôts ou pour supprimer beaucoup de
beaucoup de niches fiscales l'obs et
c'est une série d'augmentations d'impôts
moi je n'en trouvais de métis grâce à
vous à vos yeux par exemple je sais pas
ça peut être une deuxième journée de
solidarité augmenter la csg
mais on nous a dit m je crois encore
dans les gouvernements jeu j cei et le
gouvernement à n'y aura aucune
augmentation d'impôts aucune c'est donc
qu'on veut on supprime pas de niches
fiscales supprimées niches fiscales
c'est augmenter les impôts et on
n'augmente pas les impôts directement ou
indirectement donc la réponse de 2,7 de
ce2 ce2 ce spécialiste
c'est être des inspecteurs des finances
sérieuse et une réponse sérieuse c'est
celle de l'augmentation d'un poseur on
trouve une nouvelle ressource
au départ le gouvernement s'est dit je
vais affectés vous savez cette crds qui
utilisés pour rembourser la dette
sociale mais manque de pot chaque fois
qu'on a eu c'est un peu comme si j -ph
on a eu trop chez on arrive au bout en
haut de la montagne qui paf le rocher
retour tombe en bas et on se retrouve
avec 136 milliards d'euros qu'on remet
dans la cas des skis l'organisme qui
sert à cantonner la dette sociale et on
se dit on va de nouveau augmenter de 4
ans 5 ans 6 ans la période de
remboursement donc on utilisera on
utilisera la crds barrages
est ce que quand même quand vous lirez
autre chose la manière aussi légères
comme on ne peut pas donner au français
de de tels espoirs d'un espoir d'avoir
plus de sécurité pour assurer la
dépendance de manière aussi légère comme
pour les retraites on pouvait pas avoir
un texte aussi complexe s'était pas au
xviiie siècle c'était juste au mois de
janvier au mois de février
on a un test qui est resté au milieu du
gué là comme ça peu suspendue par le
49-3 pour une bonne raison c'est qu'il
était incompréhensible
est ce que quelqu'un ici et moi y
compris peut augmenter ce peuple
expliqué ce texte mais pas du tout parce
qu'il y avait des horizons à 30 ans il y
avait des horizons à deux ans il y avait
des horizons à 5 ans la personne se
disait est ce que j'aurai une retraite
plus garantie est ce que je serai sûr de
l'obtenir en face des cotisations que je
mets et est ce que ce que j'aurai un bon
niveau de moi je pense que toutes les
réformes un peu compliqué et réformer un
pays c'est compliqué sont à peu près
enterré on va y toucher parce que le
gouvernement va voleurs vouloir donner
l'impression d'y être allé et il nous
restera que la partie dépenses c'est à
dire la partie
sucré quoi c'est tellement plus facile
on a toujours procéder comme ça et mais
dans une période aussi grave que celle
là il faut rompre avec ces pratiques
on va parler de la crise à l'italie oui
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est que comme
c'est devenu presque le feuilleton le
rendez-vous hélas attendu par les ai
parlé français savoir à quelle sauce on
va être mangé avec les nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires qui pourrait
s'appliquer notamment sur paris vu des
indicateurs qui atteignent des niveaux
de rouge carmin alors on ne sait plus
d'ailleurs comme on doit le qualifier ce
rouge rouge très rouge
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement finalement a fait le bon
choix en fermant les bars restaurants à
marseille où est ce que vous comprenez
la fronde qui a agité les élus et les
professionnels du secteur mais je
comprends le désespoir
je comprends le désespoir d'un
professionnel on serait sa place non
exactement la même donc je pas du tout
juger du comportement des professionnels
c'est évidemment absolument effroyable
de replonger mais je ne peux pas je peux
pas soutenir la désobéissance la
désobéissance à la loi
et ça c'est juste pas possible aucun élu
ne peut se mettre contre la loi il ya
d'autant plus que ça a été un peu limite
1 chez certains élus du bas ils ont tort
oui mais on fait du clientélisme mais
ils ont tort ils ont bien tort fait du
club et il avait les mêmes logiques
clientélisme enfin si vous l'appelez
comme comme vous voulez c'est compliqué
prendre position contre contre des
mesures qui sont par principe
ces mesures sont impopulaires et à juste
titre encore une fois comment peut-on
donc il faut les soutenir il faut
compenser si c'est la bonne mesure moi
je suis pas épidémiologistes donc je
n'en sais rien si c'est la bonne mesure
et dieu sait qu'il ya autant des piliers
67 millions d'épidémiologistes
maintenant un peu comme les entraîneurs
de foot mais manque de pot ça a quand
même un tout petit peu plus de
conséquences
on voit bien que s'il faut fermer les
endroits où les gens se retrouvent où
nous nous retrouvons il faut le faire
ici si on note que l'incohérence entre
eux se retrouver chez soi à nombreux
faire une fête à 20
non absolument et pointent très très
bien ses incohérences
il ya beaucoup d'accords ans puisque la
vie est partout donc vous ne pouvez pas
exercer les mêmes contraintes partout
sauf à avoir un confinement généraliser
ce qui alors là ce serait une
catastrophe absolue
si on veut éviter ce confinement
généralisée alors il faut en passer par
des mesures de maîtrise plus forte est
ce que cela est une bonne mesure
ça je ne peux pas le dire mais si le
gouvernement le fait j'espère que
j'espère qu'il a un peu réfléchi à tout
ça
donc si le gouvernement ne fait à un
moment donné on n'est pas content on dit
on demande des compensations très forte
immédiat on a pas d'impôt pendant un an
pendant deux ans enfin je pense qu'il
faut aller très très loin là dessus pour
ldc ces secteurs là mais il peut pas y
avoir de l'apple par des nuls les élus
peuvent traduire ce mécontentement dire
que ça ne va pas dire que le
gouvernement était laxiste pendant toute
la période de l'été dire un certain
nombre de choses comme ça mais on
pouvait pas dire plus aux arrêts des
gestes barrières qu'ils font barrière à
rien donc il faut un moment donné que la
barrière sur l'oise un mot sur la
céleste est le premier département
touché lors de la première vague votre
département et florence parly la mise
des armées qui a admis devant les
sénateurs que les militaires de la base
de creil n'avait pas été testée
contrairement à ce qu'elle avait affirmé
il y a quelques semaines qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette révélation où
elle ne savait pas quand elle l'a quand
elle a dit ça est au début et c'est
quand même un peu surprenant où elle le
savait hélas menti donc si c'est pas
c'est pas une très bonne
une très bonne chose puisque les
commission denquête au sénat et à
l'assemblée il faudra évidemment
auditionné la ministre pour savoir
comment elle a pu changer d'avis en
aussi peu de temps ou la modifier
pourquoi nous faut savoir pourquoi on a
considéré à un moment donné qu'il y
avait des tests après que n'a pas eue
quoi ça peut être un défaut
d'information comme ça peut être une
volonté de clairement masquer la
situation si je puis dire en tout cas à
creil en tout cas personne ne sait
comment cette pandémie et est arrivé
visiblement l'institut pasteur a fait
beaucoup de recherches sur ce bassin de
crépy en valois de crèches au sud ouest
du département de l'oise il y avait des
doutes sur le militaire de la base de
café il ya eu envie et ce moment où est
donc je crois qu'on ne sait pas bien je
ne sais pas d'ailleurs si c'est encore
un intérêt en tout cas dans le
département de l'oise nous ne sommes pas
dans le rouge rouge
plus plus j'espère qu'on n'y sera pas
mais une situation très différente selon
l'est où le sud du département
le nord ou le centre du département
c'est plus inquiétant à l'est et un peu
au sud du département
une dernière question sur votre parti eh
bien écoutez oui demain on doit on
s'attend à un discours du président sur
sur le séparatisme et on se posait la
question de savoir si pour vous il était
temps que ce discours arrive pour lutter
contre l'islam radical notamment
enfin il est patent que le discours
arriva honnêtement le discours on en n'a
pas enfin pas grand chose à faire c'est
pas la question dissous faut pas mettre
des grands mots je sais c'est qu'en
france on met toujours d'énormes mots
pour de tout petit action il faut juste
voir ce que le président de la
république va proposer comme mesure
contre l'islam radical
il a décidé d'appeler ca séparatisme
pourquoi pas - ou communautarisme ça
mais ça m'est un peu égal
enfin les mots ont toujours très grande
importance mais il faut faire attention
à ce qu il ne dévie pas de chance on
veut lutter contre l'islamisme radical
pas contre l'islam mais ça je pense que
grande partie de deux français l'ont
compris il faut le répéter
inlassablement une grande religion donc
inlassablement
mais ça produit un islam de barbarie de
radicalisme d'obscurantisme de folie
enfin bon il ya des dingues un peu
partout et là il y en a vraiment des
détails extrêmement dangereux on le voit
tout le temps donc ils veulent gangréner
la société allait aux sociétés
démocratiques de se défendre ce que nous
ce que nous nous faisons il faut durcir
évidemment les choses mais les durcir
vraiment vraiment vraiment donc on verra
ce que dit le président de la république
moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il dira vous ne
savez pas non plus on verra si c'est pas
la énième loi si on va pas nous annoncer
à nouveau texte qui sera appliqué à
moitié c'est fou ce que la france se
répète la france béguin pour vous la
france elle bégaye tout le temps il ya
d'autres pays qui province jardel tous
les autres tous les pays ont leur propre
faiblesse n'y a pas et heureusement la
france est un pays où encore il fait il
fait encore bon vivre et c'est difficile
à dire en ces temps difficiles mais il
fait encore bon vivre enfin quand même
il ya un moment donné on peut pas avoir
les mêmes débats pendant 10 ans 15 ans
même si lorsqu'ils concernent la
l'islamisme radical
la menace a évidemment considérablement
évolué mais on peut pas sans arrêt se
poser les mêmes questions de toute
nature la question du temps de travail
la question de la de la décentralisation
et la centralisation et que la question
des communautarismes la question des
banlieues bon toutes ces questions on a
le sentiment qu'à un moment donné il ya
une grande loi parce que toutes les lois
sont grandes
maintenant ok une grande loi et puis in
fine et on s'aperçoit que sa part et
zouzou lui grand chose donc il faut que
ce texte
si un texte je pense que j'imagine
attendu ce texte résolve résolve
clairement les choses telles qu'on peut
les constater aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'occasion d'en reparler merci beaucoup
électeurs faisant persie d'être venu
merci julien va regarder la une de la
voix du nord l'alertent et général c'est
la crise sanitaire bien sûr qui est à la
une de la voix du nord merci messieurs
on passe ensuite au club des territoires